hi I'm sanjana Reddy a machine learning
engineer at Google's Advanced Solutions
lab
there's been a lot of excitement around
generative Ai and all the new
advancements including new vertex AI
features that are coming up such as gen
AI Studio model Garden genei API
our objective in this short session is
to give you a solid footing on some of
the underlying Concepts that make all
the Gen AI magic possible
today I'm going to talk about
Transformer models and the Bert model
language modeling has evolved over the
years
the recent breakthroughs in the past 10
years include the usage of neural
networks to represent text such as word
to whack and engrams in 2013.
in 2014 the development of sequence to
sequence models such as rnns and lstms
helped improve the performance of ml
models on NLP tasks such as translation
and text classification
in 2015 the excitement came with
attention mechanisms and the models
built based on it such as Transformers
and the bird model
in this presentation we'll focus on
Transformers
Transformers is based on a 2017 paper
named attention is all you need
although all the models before
Transformers were able to represent
verbs as vectors these vectors did not
contain the context
and the usage of words changes based on
the context for example Bank in
Riverbank versus Bank in bank robber
might have the same Vector
representation before attention
mechanisms came about a Transformer is
an encoder decoder model that uses the
attention mechanism
it can take advantage of parallelization
and also process a large amount of data
at the same time because of its model
architecture
attention mechanism helps improve the
performance of machine translation
applications
Transformer models were built using
attention mechanisms at the core
a Transformer model consists of encoder
and decoder
the encoder encodes the input sequence
and passes it to the decoder and the
decoder
decodes a representation for irrelevant
task
the encoding component is a stack of
encoders of the same number the research
paper that introduced Transformers
Stacks 6 encoders on top of each other
six is not a magical number it's just a
hyper parameter
the encoders are all identical in
structure but with different weights
each encoder can be broken down into two
sub-layers
the first layer is called the
self-attention
the input of the encoder first flows
through a self-attention layer which
helps the encoder look at relevant parts
of the words as it encodes a center word
in the input sentence
and the second layer is called a feed
forward layer the output of the
self-attention layer is fed to the feed
forward neural network
the exact same feed forward neural
network is independently applied to each
position
the decoder has both the self-attention
and the feed forward layer but between
them is the encoder decoder attention
layer that helps the decoder focus on
relevant parts of the input sentence
after embedding the words in the input
sequence each of the embedding Vector
flows through the two layers of the
encoder
the word at each position passes through
a self-attention process then it passes
through a feed-forward neural network
the exact same network with each Vector
flowing through it separately
dependencies exist between these paths
in the self attention layer
however the feed forward layer does not
have these dependencies and therefore
various paths can be executed in
parallel while they flow through the
feed forward layer
in the self-attention layer the input
embedding is broken up into query key
and value vectors
these vectors are computed using weights
that the Transformer learns during the
training process
all of these computations happen in
parallel in the model in the form of
Matrix computations
once we have the query key and value
vectors the next step is to multiply
each value vector by the softmax score
in preparation to sum them up the
intuition here is to keep intact the
values of the words you want to focus on
and leave out irrelevant words by
multiplying them by tiny numbers like
0.001 for example
next we have to sum up the weighted
value vectors
which produces the output of the
self-attention layer at this position
for the first word you can send along
the resulting Vector to the feedforward
neural network
to sum up this process of getting the
final embeddings these are the steps
that we take
we start with the natural language
sentence
embed each word in the sentence
after that we perform multi-headed
attention eight times in this case and
multiply this embedded word with the
respective weighted matrices
we then calculate the attention using
the resulting qkv matrices
finally we concatenate the matrices to
produce the output Matrix which is the
same Dimension as the final Matrix that
this layer initially got
there's multiple variations of
Transformers out there now
some use both the encoder and the
decoder component from the original
architecture some use only the encoder
and some use only the decoder
a popular encoder only architecture is
Bert
Bert is one of the trained Transformer
models Bert stands for bi-directional
encoder representations from
Transformers and was developed by Google
in 2018.
since then multiple variations of bird
have been built today Bert Powers Google
search
you can see how different the results
provided by Bert are for the same search
query before and after
it was trained in two variations one
model contains bird base which had 12
stack of Transformers with approximately
110 million parameters and the other
bird large with 24 layers of
Transformers with about 340 million
parameters
the bird model is powerful because it
can handle long input context
it was trained on the entire Wikipedia
Corpus and Books Corpus
the bird model was trained for 1 million
steps Bert is trained on different tasks
which means it has multi-task objective
this makes Bert very powerful
because of the kind of tasks it was
trained on it works at both a sentence
level and at a token level
these are the two different versions of
Bert that were originally released one
is bird base which had 12 layers whereas
bird large had 24 layers and compared to
the original Transformer which had six
layers
the way that bird works is that it was
trained on two different tasks task one
is called a masked language model where
the sentences are masked and the model
is trained to predict the masked words
if you were to train bird from scratch
you would have to mask a certain
percentage of the words in your Corpus
the recommended percentage for masking
is 15 percent
the masking percentage achieves a
balance between too little and too much
masking do little masking makes the
training process extremely expensive and
too much masking removes the contacts
that the model requires
the second task is to predict the next
sentence
for example the model is given two sets
of sentences Bert aims to learn the
relationships between sentences and
predict the next sentence given the
first one
for example sentence a could be a man
went to the store and sentence B is he
bought a gallon of milk
bird is responsible for classifying if
sentence B is the next sentence after
sentence a
this is a binary classification task
this helps Bert perform at a sentence
level
in order to train Bert you need to feed
three different kinds of embeddings to
the model
for the input sentence you get three
different embeddings token segment and
position embeddings
the token embeddings is a representation
of each token as an embedding in the
input sentence
the words are transformed into Vector
representations of certain dimensions
bird can solve NLP tasks that involve
text classification as well
an example is to classify whether two
sentences say my dog is cute and he
likes playing are semantically similar
the pairs of input texts are simply
concatenated and fed into the model how
does bird distinguish the inputs in a
given pair the answer is to use segment
embeddings
there is a special token represented by
SCP that separates the two different
splits of the sentence
another problem is to learn the order of
the words in the sentence
as you know bird consists of a stack of
Transformers Bert is designed to process
input sequences up to a length of 512.
the order of the input sequence is
incorporated into the position
embeddings this allows Bert to learn a
vector representation for each position
vert can be used for different
Downstream tasks although Bert was
trained on mass language modeling and
single sentence classification it can be
used for popular NLP tasks like single
sentence classification sentence pair
classification question answering and
single sentence tagging tasks
thank you for listening